you
I'm going to talk about a specific point
that and you talked about which is that
we got rid of all the C code it's not
that we don't like C I probably written
more C than any other language out there
but there are reasons to get rid of it
and it was also a really interesting
process but mostly what I want to talk
about
so as I'm you said as of the 1.5 release
the entire system is written in go
there's also some assembler but not very
much the point is the C is gone they're
still C go but outside of that kind of
thing there's no C in the runtime of the
tool train now lectures are stressed
that I'm talking about the GC compiler
now GCC go still still is written in C++
and uses and that's still going strong
so it's not a general replacement
although I suspect the runtime work that
we've thrown a lot of it which is
inbound
so first question is why was it in C in
the first place there's a question a lot
of language experts asses because it's
well-known that what you always do is
you write their language in itself we
didn't do that we didn't do it because
we wanted an easy bootstrapping process
if you don't have a if go doesn't exist
it's very hard to run the go compiler
and so it's easier to take an existing
language like C or for the GCC go C++
writes compiler in that also there's a
subtle effect if you write the language
in terms of itself the language becomes
a language suited for writing compilers
especially and although that's an
interesting thing it wasn't really what
we were after so we didn't really care
what the language was it was written in
but at some point it became harder for
us to maintain the C language and the go
language side by side we want to just
move it to go so why move the compiler
as I said it's not for validating our
work we have very pragmatic motives and
their simple go is easier to write than
C go is easier to debug than C also if
there's only one language you have to
know instead of two it's easier to get
contributions from the community and
that's already happening and much faster
than it did when it was this C language
compiler go also has much better
modularity to say that C has any is a
bit of
overstatement and of course we've got
the awesome tooling that comes with go
which we can use to improve the compiler
and work on it there's actually unit
tests for the compiler now imagine that
and also a point that is actually
relevant as go makes parallel execution
trivial so you can imagine running the
compiler in parallel and that's actually
something sort of happening and so we're
already seeing these benefits even
though that it's only really been
working for a couple of months now and
there's a design doc called go one free
compiler which it was the announcement
was made around one free although we
knew a few releases before I really got
done but it's not just that compiler
move the runtime move too and so we had
actually our own C compiler to run for
just for writing the runtime for go now
it wasn't a single a girl from scratch
it was essentially a lot on exactly the
plan nine C compiler and we needed one
because we needed our own ABI so that
the we could do things like have the
segmented stacks work when go called C
for through the runtime and not have
that break so it was very sort of subtle
problem having two languages of co-exist
having owning both both compilers the C
compiler and the go compiler running the
same world made it a lot easier to
manage it so it's actually a really good
idea for us to do this but of course it
we had this weird extra C compiler that
seemed strange
we couldn't use GCC to do that and so
this process really important part of
this process is converting the runtime
to go means you can delete an entire an
entire compiler from our tool chain and
that's a huge deal right compiler nice
and of course all the reasons I mention
on the previous slide work for the
runtime to your gonna test that works
better profiling and so on and so on and
so now there's only one language we have
to maintain which means there's only one
set of stack management software we have
to write there's only one set of data
management and this kind of stuff it's
much much simpler and as usual when I'm
giving a talk it's all about simplicity
so there's a question that comes up
though in this which is why do we have
our own tool chain at all why don't we
just build everything on top of
something that was already out there and
that's a pretty good question we even
considered using LOV m for about 20
minutes in the early days but decided it
was just too slow we wanted a fast
compiler but we had our own reasons for
having our
API which involve are involved with
things like how the stack gets laid out
and how to do go routine switching and
this kind of stuff that sort of
integrated fundamentally into the the
some level of the compile world and so
we just Chuck what we're familiar with
which was supply line tool set and not
exactly but to some extent brought it
over and made it work and so because we
were familiar with that we know how to
work on it it's actually very small
compared to like GCC or LLVM we could
move quickly with it and that was a I
think Russ once said if we'd started
with LOV M we probably would have gone
very far not the same thing wrong with
oo VM it just doesn't have our goals in
life there was last year a rather rude
blog post complaining about our ABI
which I won't go into in detail but Ross
wrote a very thoughtful response to it
which is worth reading because he
explains these issues in great detail
and I think did a really good job better
than I can and so as a result of moving
to go we can now do things that were not
really possible I mean literally not
possible before
for instance we completely reading we
architected linker we put in the new
garbage collector that Andrew talked
about and that Rick will talk about at
length at gopher con and that includes
things like stack maps which are way to
track what's live corner data on the
stack the new contiguous stack work we
used to segments we want a stack guru we
allocate a new block and jump to that
and then jump back when you return now
if we hit the bottom of the stack we
actually allocate a whole new stack copy
the data over which means you've got to
update all the point get all that right
and then run on that new world and
that's a pretty big change and then the
right barriers that are necessary to
have a concurrent garbage collector
those last three things were actually
pretty close to be impossible to do if
they're seeing your runtime because C is
not typeset you don't know whether a
word is a point or not it might be a
union that's a pointer sometimes a
floating-point number on Wednesdays
you just don't know and there's also
lots of aliasing that goes on do two
optimizations in C programs because the
compiler can recognize that this cell in
this part of the function can have one
type but I can reuse a cell down here
and that kind of stuff it's very
difficult to follow you can use stack
maps to help you although it's hard
hard hard and see but for instance
integrating that into the C compiler of
any stripe is a very big deal and now
that we don't have a secret by to worry
about that whole problem just vanishes
so that's tremendous and sort of proof
of the pudding is we expect that GCC go
which is written using a GCC back-end
will probably have segmented stacks and
imprecise stack data collection for you
know the foreseeable future essentially
maybe one day but not anytime soon
so what about those stacks well in one
up to up to 1.2 stacks for these
segmented things then in 1.3 that's the
time we decided we wanted to make this
move we had to plan the new garbage
collector the new compiler moving all
this other stuff and so the first thing
we did was Keith Randolph suggested this
making these contiguous stacks but you
can't do contiguous stacks with C code
because you can't move the stack data
because you don't know what's a pointer
so the first step was to implement
contiguous stacks unless you're in C
code so in C code is running you
actually go back to Cygnus - so
basically in the run time sometimes you
were in contiguous tags sometimes you
weren't then in 1.4 we pushed harder on
this and made the stacks contiguous by
restricting where C could run to be only
on the system's tag would literally jump
stacks when you're going into c
so that was cleaner and then for 1.5
well you get rid of C code the problem
goes away and now we always have
contiguous stats and that's more
efficient and just much better and also
helps the garbage quicker and also
independently of converting the compiler
we had to convert the runtime which of
course was a stack work happen and that
was mostly done by hand with machine
assistance and the tricky part is
writing the runtime in a type safe
language which is pretty much impossible
without breaking a rule and the way you
break the rule is you use essentially
the unsafe package and maybe a couple
other tricks for instance you have to in
the garbage collector look at a pointer
value as a bit pattern in order to do
things like set mark bits and that kind
of thing and so you have to use unsafe
to do this it turns out though there's
much less of that then certainly I
expected was necessary which implies
that we had the right kind of tool set
for doing this kind
even though NGO is type safe we have a
really good escape valve that's just
kind of the right shape to make things
possible to write a full runtime in this
type safe language and only cheat when
we really have to and also to convert
the runtime there's a lot of code to
translate some of it was done
automatically which I'll talk about now
so the biggest job the biggest single
job in all of this probably was
converting the compiler from C to go now
you might think well why did you
translate it why didn't just write a new
one and that's a very good question and
it doesn't have a simple answer for
instance we could take the Roberts go
ast and parser and so on build that up
write a new back-end or a couple to the
back end and there's there's good reason
for doing that and good reasons for not
doing that
but we decided to go with a translation
for now at least primarily for
correctness the C C version of the go
compiler is a big program it's actually
about more than twice as big as the C
version of the C compiler and it's got a
lot of subtle things that we've tracked
down bugs we fixed semantic details
we've worked on and we know that those
work and if we can translate the code
and produce an identical program in a
different language we just have a lot
less to worry about we're not going to
introduce new subtle bugs in this
process and so we decided to translate
it but of course you don't want to
translate it by hand that's annoying so
naturally what we do what we do it's
sort of a full-time job we wrote a
program to write a program and so Russ
wrote this custom translator that turns
seeing to go and then you run that
translated program to get the output you
run the compiler that results which is
now a go program but it's still a go
compiler it should generate exactly the
same output because it's the same
program just in a different language if
it doesn't generate the same program you
have a bug you track down the bug and
you fix it so you iterate until you have
two versions of the compiler that
generate exactly the same output and
then you know you have a correct go
compiler even though it's machine
generated and then the result of course
is really bad code because this machine
translated but then you can sit there
using the awesome tools that we have to
work on go code to make it much much
nicer and that's still going on
today so the translator was done by this
line-by-line translation and I can't go
to the full detail Russ talked about a
little bit ago for Kahn last year but
it's actually turned into quite a
different thing than what he talked
about it's a little bit different I want
to stress that this is not a
general-purpose see to go translator
that job is just too hard we had a very
specific program written in C in a
certain style by a certain person can
and we knew how to translate that
dialect basically but the general
dialect is beyond this tool so the first
thing you do was parse the C code Russ
had a yak grammar in his back pocket
it's kind of thing he carries around
with him and we translated the C program
into you know a parse tree go into it
fix anything that you can't represent
inside go an example the star P plus
plus uses an expression in in go star P
plus plus as a statement and so you you
do what rewrites you have to now you
have a C parse tree that's been
simplified to go if you like but it's
still a C program now you print it as a
go program so you just change the syntax
when you print the tree it's actually
pretty easy to do relatively speaking
now you have a go program that's a goal
line by line translation of a C program
into a go program compile that and then
do the cycle I talked about the previous
page now the parser for the compiler is
written in yak and that was actually
hand Trey's translated using sand to do
mostly heavy lifting so that wasn't run
by the translator but it's a relatively
small piece of things and much simpler
to do so the translator sort of
automatically can't do absolutely
everything he needs a little bit of help
and so there's a sort of configuration
thing that sits on the side of the
translator that tells you things that it
might not be able to intuit easily
itself like this structure field is a
bool even though it's declared as an int
because he doesn't have pools at least
old C doesn't or this function returns a
bool and then for more complicated
things like recognizing that this
pattern is better done by calling on a
standard library
there was a kind of dislike syntax for
generating these matches and then this
thing here you can see this isn't C code
because at this point you have a seat
tree represented in go syntax so this is
what the tree looks like in go code now
and you can replace this wretched stuff
with a call to me
or a couple of calls to make as another
example of these kind of differs this
one C basically doesn't define what
shift is it's just it's just very
confused but in go they're very
rigorously defined and so you can take
this fairly messy C program to make sure
you get the right answer always even
when C doesn't tell you what's gonna go
on you can replace it with a simple
shift because go is better behaved in
this respect and so there's a bunch of
these configuration things there's
typically generated by finding the bug
in the output or a bad piece of code
once you have this working you now have
a go program that looks like a C program
that's been translated mechanically and
so now we can bring the tools of go on
to bear on fixing it up and so Russ
again wrote this tool called grind I
don't know why it's called that but it
did a lot of grinding I guess I ground
the rough edges off and it now is in go
so we can parse the go program the
results do type checking on it and then
writes down a list of things it wants to
change what it does not do is edit the
parse tree because it's kind of hard to
edit parse trees it's annoying it's a
it's a clumsy thing to do what this
thing does instead is represent
everything is source text but parses it
to see what to do
writes down a list of source edits like
on line 27 move this line down 1 or
something like that and then when he
prints it out you execute that edit
chain to generate new source code so
it's actually a source to source
translator by but not by manipulating
the source the parse tree and the
changes that it executes are driven by
various analyses and a lot of staring at
the screen things like removing dead
code and unnecessary go twos getting rid
of labels in directions that don't need
to be there and stuff like that and then
one I'll talk about quite a bit moving
for declarations around which turns out
to be important
so this was the big tool for fixing up
the crappy code that came out of the
translator now what happened was the
first time the translator generated a
working compiler and we ran it on a real
piece of code it was using the HTML
template test suite as a test case it
was ten times slower than the previous
compiler not because go is intrinsically
slower but because the code was so
terrible right but the question is
what's wrong with the code that comes
out and we actually learned quite a bit
in understanding why it was so slow and
speeding it up most of which we've
gotten back then it's still a little
slower but it's nothing like 10x the
main thing is is a combination of things
that C does differently from go for
instance if you in C you tend write
really complicated for loop conditions
and go doesn't do that very well it's
not intended to and so what the
translator would do is if there was
complex 4 condition it would put it
inside a closure because that's the
easiest way to get a single expression
to be a complicated thing and so all
these for loops in the compiler were
turned into closure grunge on the
iterators which was really expensive
relative to regular for loop so we you
know by hand or mechanically would
rewrite those complex expressions to
make the code more go idiomatic a really
important thing is that on C by
definition because it doesn't work
variables on the stack never escaped to
the heap by definition the staff is just
the stack there's no there's no moving
back and forth between them the way
there isn't go and so if there's a
variable on the stack in the C version
of the compiler you know that that does
not escape to the heat but by the time
it becomes a go program the go compiler
might not understand that and so things
get put on the heap that don't need to
be because semantically it's too hard to
figure out for the automatic translator
and that caused some slowdown because
things that we really didn't have to
their interfaces that hide some of this
heat escape possibility like the way
from toast ringer works was just a much
cheaper VARs and C intrinsically non
intrinsically cheaper but in practice
can be cheaper and then there's things
like the lack of unions and go the C
compiler has this massive Union in it to
save memory and there are no unions and
goes so that became struct which made
bigger which made use more
which hurt the cash and so on and so on
so tried to squeeze some of those
structures down to improve the density
of the memory and then probably the most
important single thing is that variable
declarations were in the wrong place
when you enter a c function we were
talking about CC 89 SEC you always put
there all the declarations for the
function right at the top opening brace
here you know into I charged RPE
whatever and in the compiler there were
some very very big functions like the
thing called walk that walks a tree
repeatedly and it starts with a massive
block of declared variables but on any
given call of that function only two or
three of those variables might get used
but every time that funds get called go
would say oops escape analysis on this
function and push all these variables
out to the heat that didn't need to be
weird even gonna be used let alone need
to escape and that was a major cause of
GCC over GC GC overhead bloat and so on
and so on and so one of the biggest
things grinded was turned that big block
of declarations at the top of a C
function now and go and broke it down
into moving the variables to where
they're actually used so that they're
the variables only get allocated and
created when they're needed during
execution not every time every function
is called
and that was a huge speed up doing that
another way to think about this is it
the C compiler doesn't ever free
anything - pretty much it's not
literally true but it's pretty much true
it just allocates stuff because it's got
to find that run it's going to be
finished doesn't have to maintain
anything and so it doesn't have any
basically no allocation especially free
over it whereas the go there's garbage
collector and it doesn't know that the
compile is going to complete that's
called the whole thing problem and so it
has to assume it needs to collect memory
and so the garbage collector provides a
certain overhead here that is just
unavoidable but of course we're working
hard on making the compiler better but
anyway this is a lot of interesting
technical analysis about how seeing go
are fundamentally different languages in
a lot of surprising or not so surprising
ways so we fixed a lot of these things
pretty easily we move variables closer
to where they're first used that huge
fact we'd also take it variable and make
multiple versions of that variable
through a function in order to allocate
them only you know uniquely for each
place we find places in the compiler
where a library routine which was
optimized heavily could be used instead
of some generated go code that wasn't
very good somewhat related but not
exactly we replaced the multi precision
arithmetic that was inside the compiler
for doing expression evaluation for
constants and we placed that with the
math big package which is a very
efficient and correct it turns out
implementation of multi precision
arithmetic we use some tricks to make
the structure fields collapse we sort of
simulate unions using interfaces which
adds a certain computational overhead
but it's a win because it reduces the
memory so much David Chase a new member
of the team has been doing much better
escape analysis so that the difference
between what the C compiler does and
what the go compare does is shrank
significantly and then of course a lot
of hand tuning and data layout and
profiling and so on and so on and much
of this was done by automatic tools like
grind I mentioned but also just go for
minus R and the new tool eg that Alan
Donovan wrote for doing a lot of this
work as then it as a surprising example
while I was working on something I
thought one minute we I wanted to fix
that a simplify some debugging prints
inside the library that the compiler the
linker and the assembly yours and to do
this I actually got rid of an interface
in an argument replaced it with just
maybe just be methods so as a print
method instead of a springer I feel like
and this is only used for debugging it
was never called in a typical compile
but when I made that change to a library
the compiler sped up 15% and the reason
is that because it might be called in
debugging the compilers escape analysis
decided it's going to interface we don't
know what's going to do this all these
variables have to go to the heap and
that was a fundamental data structure
whose escaping that didn't need to
escape so totally by accident by fixing
a print routine to simplify it I made
the compiler 15% faster because our
escape analysis has got a ways to go
and there's tons more to do and this
work is ongoing so technical benefits of
doing this besides the one I mentioned
probably the single most important thing
that's true now is that because there is
no C code no contributor in the
community is going to submit a dangling
pointer bug to the repository that's a
huge win but also in doing this it gives
the chance to clean up the backhands we
did a major refactoring which I mention
I'm talking a little bit more in a
minute one of the things that's really
cool is we've now unified two of the
architectures so the 386 32 and 64-bit
architectures are now really just one
inside the tool chain so it just reduces
the amount of code and complexity that's
kind of neat it's now much easier to
install a new architecture for a variety
of reasons one of which is that you
don't have to worry about the C compiler
and we also in the process have now
unified the tool chain as as Andrew
mentioned there's now only one compiler
one assembler and one linker so now when
you want to compile normally you just
use go build of course but if you're not
using go build you're running it by hand
perhaps from a make file you just say go
to a compile and you change the
architecture in the operating system
just with the standard Busan Gorch
they're officially pronounced and so you
just normally would say go to a compile
tool link that kind of thing so now
there's only one compiler it's a single
binary and that programs job is to
compile go program into the target
architecture and target operating system
has to find just by two environment
variables which is a little simple than
I think porting and some other systems I
know and so 6g and HG they're gone
5g Dungey they're all gone you just have
one compiler enough and that's that
compiler at the end of this process one
at the end but where we are now it's
about 50,000 lines of portable code and
then but because of this refactoring
that was made possible to the go tooling
being available we actually made a lot
more of the code portable than used to
be so there's a lot of duplicated code
in C that was very hard to unify letting
go is a lot easier so for instance
there's all those only one compiler in
multiple architectures there's only one
register riser the register ization
passed
Tyler is purely portable code that's
controlled by simple configuration
that's part of the architecture
definition so it's actually a kind of
cool thing there's a little bit of non
portable code it's typically around 10%
of the size of the portable part so a
few thousand lines the x86 of course has
got more than some of the others but the
tricky parts include things like people
optimization and knowing things like
this register gets written over if you
do a shift and that kind of thing but
for the most part like 90% of the code
is now completely portable and that also
of course makes things much easier to
work on there's also a totally new
assembler just for fun I wanted a
project so I decided to write an
assembler rather than we have Translate
assemblers which I can use as a
reference when I was doing the work but
now there's just one assembler entirely
running go
and of course it's there for a lot of
Nitra code to start with it's only about
4,000 lines of which again less than
actually quite a bit less than in the
compiler relatively speaking is machine
dependent and it's also with a couple of
minor tweaks completely compatible with
the old one so it's again a complete you
know move to go with the existing tool
what's interesting now is if you think
about it when you're looking at the
compiler the input language is the same
right you always have you know func
printf and all that stuff the assembler
is not a language you think you have a
supportable input language but guess
what it is and now this is one of the
things where the guy who blogged about
me being a world-class jackass really
missed the point the assembler syntax
that can wrote define back in the plan
nine days it's all caps and looks like a
sixtieth thousand no matter what your
architecture is that seems annoying to
people who love a semi language but that
make but the fact that is actually a
portable language means that you can do
something like this have a single
assembler in a few thousand lines of
code for all the architectures in the
world and if you want to add a new
architecture it takes you very very
little time and I'm gonna tell you a
little more about how we do that in a
minute it's totally an
accident of the kind of history that can
is responsible for which is having idea
really early on the 20 years later you
go that's what he was thinking okay and
so there's also this unified back-end
logic which is a single library with a
single API for all of the architecture
so this it was actually really fun to
write this program and think about how
different it was from the way people
usually think about assembler and then
of course the same thing after the
linker there's not only one linker and
o6l Noel this was mostly done but to use
the translation tool and a lot of
handing in combat as before it's
actually the first part movement thing
and part of it was was hide off into a
library called internal flash mobs or
just basically the back end of the
linker it says instruction selection
knows how to format instructions
generate object code and all that kind
of stuff and if you look across all of
the machinery now there's about 27
thousand lines of code there which is
fairly big but it includes the
definition of the instruction sets for
all these machines so it's quite a bit
of stuff but now this was related to my
my 50% speed up in the compiler that I
was responsible for there's now one
printf so anywhere in the in the tool
chain you can print out a node or not a
node and the compiler sense but the
linker sense and it'll print out the
instruction you know standard what we
call portable assembler format so it's
human readable it's just one one
subroutine to do all that so it's the
kind of thing you get when you're
unified it's really nice now there's a
bootstrap problem there's no C compiler
anymore and I'm on a machine that
doesn't have any go compiler how do I
boot well the answer is go get a go
compiler just go download one that's the
way to do it and so basically you need a
1.4 compiler because the 1.5 port
depends on a couple of features at 1.4
and we'll try I think to keep relatively
close to that so you grab the 1.4 build
as a binary just download it from the
website put it in a go 1.4 directory and
then you can build some source the 1.5
and all the following guys on it sounds
a little own it's actually not a big
deal at all you can read what how it
works
go on the bootstrap say so what's what's
the future well there's not a lot of
work to do but we're pretty much frozen
for 1.5 so we probably I'm going to be a
little bit faster it's still a little
slower than it used to be but we don't
want to make big changes now we're in
the freeze so it'll get faster later but
it's done now it all works
everything we've talked about today's we
all but there's much more to do down the
road for 1.6 and after we're gonna
better escape analysis which has a huge
effect on performance be better garbage
collector stuff there's a new compiler
back-end using static single assignment
that Keith Randle's working on that will
make it possible to do much better
optimizations in the compiler which have
a huge effect doing things like
sub-expression elimination eliminating
index bound checks and that kind of
thing and this is the kind of thing
that's now that it's in go you go I was
gonna be easy now whereas and see
probably take a lot any other so lightly
so we expect the compiler generated code
will improve markedly in the releases to
come the thing that I'm looking forward
to is we have a portable assembler and I
don't want to write the tables for those
assemblers so Russ has a tool that he's
been working on that will read a machine
instruction set as a PDF and printer and
assembler instruction set and it's it's
actually been used to write the
disassemblers that are there now but we
haven't coupled it to the front of the
assembler so the idea is that the
manufacturer will either give you or
your big borrow and steal the PDF or
perhaps the XML there's an argument that
arm might give us an XML description of
their instruction set we turn a crank
and you get a new assembler for a new
architecture that'll be pretty nice
that's the way computing supposed to
work so concluding getting se was sounds
like a fairly small thing but I think is
actually the one of the biggest deals
the 1.5 is a huge release with C gone
the new garbage collector or the new
scheduler work go mobile stuff this is
actually a big big numbered release and
so I think it's going to be one that
will stand up to stand up and we'll have
a lot of new things in there but getting
rid of code is actually one of the
biggest things
in it so we have code now all through
the tool chain all through the runtime
that's clean air tests of easier to test
easy to profile it's just going to get
cleaner and faster as time goes on we
have this new unified tool chain that
reduces the size of the of the binary if
you don't you know multiple linkers and
assemblers hanging around and there's a
lot easier to maintain now and so we
have a much more flexible tool chain a
much more flexible source code and so
things are just gonna get better as it
goes on but as always and from the
beginning portability is a key part of
this we won't go to be the most portable
language out there I think it already
pretty much is but we just want to make
it more and more portable and easy thank
you
who's next you should come in the Swap
here no we haven't thought about that
maybe the assembler is not portable in
the sense that you can take three to six
assembler and run it on an arm but the
syntax is portable and that makes a lot
of the work of the assembler much easier
you're still talking about different
instruction sets so it's not an
intermediate representation like like
the you know like the IR and LLVM it's
still this is 386 assembler even though
it looks like 16,000 but the
instructions in our 3d six instructions
and this is the arm assembler and it's
instructions or arm
it says syntax is the same and so most
of the work of the assembler is in
parsing and so it's just a portable
language in that sense if you like the
portable language with different
functions think of it that way yes
we haven't talked about that it's
certainly something to allow you to do
now there's a lot of tricky issues and I
think we don't want to step in there
while all this and maybe liquor where's
my money to make money but down the road
I'd like that it's not a small program
it's not you know it could be done
wait well they wrong